we were cheering for this yesterday and
now it has happened here Jeter going to
the Hall of Fame one more short shot was
not selected though unanimously like his
former teammate Mariano Rivera there's
one budget no one knows but he says he's
grateful he got the votes he did take a
listen I think when you start off your
career you're never thinking about the
Hall of Fame I mean this is the highest
honor that can be given to any
individual it plays this game and and
you know speechless that's amazing I
want to know the one we're gonna keep
looking into Gail let you go another
inductee Larry Walker we were talking
about him yesterday he was surrounded by
family and friends when he got the call
to the hall look at that range Bob
Squarepants so it was his 10th and final
tour enhancing to earn baseball's
highest honor and I love this guys
because it is my life he tweeted that I
believe I'm gonna come up a little short
today in other words like we all sort of
prepare for the worst but not for the
best
that's life Larry Walker is in he got in
by like 6 votes I think he was not
expected to not Kelly was overcoming his
family and friends were so happy for you
and this is the last time you could get
it yeah it's really wonderful
you